but we are going to begin this hour with
more on Hurricane Ian just hours from
landfall in Florida now we can tell you
overnight ocean water already surged in
Key West and South Florida and strong
winds spun up tornadoes around the Miami
area now this storm is just shy as we're
speaking of a category five that's 157
mile an hour sustained winds and it's
making its way up Florida's West Coast
millions of people at this hour are
under mandatory evacuations evacuation
orders there but our David begno lead
correspondent nationally for CBS
mornings is in Tampa holding strong
waiting for the storm to make landfall
David good morning again what do you
know
good morning my friend so here in the
Tampa area we're expected to get the
brunt of the rainfall from Ian I want to
show you this view from above the storm
it has reached as you said winds of up
to
155 miles per hour folks we're on the
edge of a category 5 hurricane here now
the outer bands of the hurricane have
already spawned several reported
tornadoes across Florida causing damage
to homes and knocking out power to more
than 50 000 people so far here in the
western side of the state you've got two
and a half million people under
evacuation orders south of where we are
near Fort Myers and Punta Gorda the
National Hurricane Center is now
projecting a storm surge of up to 16
feet that is nearly two stories back
here in Tampa a lot of people got out
yesterday but as we were riding around
with the sheriff's deputy we noticed a
lot of people chose to stay boarding up
their Windows Gathering sandbags to
protect their home I tossed it back
there was one hotel that cut off the
power locked the doors and called the
police saying people are refusing to get
out
see it getting darker with David yeah
you can see it already David please be
careful thank you so much